not far from the beaches of the French
Riviera the energy for our fossil fuel
free future is taking shape it's called
fusion an elusive form of nuclear energy
that's clean and safe and we've been
given special access to the site is the
world's biggest science experiment
if this experimental plant works as
expected when it's switched on in seven
years time it will be modern alchemy
turning water into bountiful energy
without the long-lived radioactive waste
of current nuclear plants nuclear energy
as we know it today is a comes from a
process called nuclear fission which is
where we split large atoms and make
smaller ones which releases a huge
amount of energy Fusion is when we put
two smaller nuclei together and fuse
them together which is the process that
happens within the Sun and this releases
even more energy than a fission reactor
would but obviously we're trying to
recreate the Sun on earth so it's a lot
more challenging to do scientists start
the fusion reaction by heating up two
forms of hydrogen gas that can be found
in seawater until they become a soup of
atomic particles called plasma ten times
hotter than the Sun that's far too hot
for any material on earth to contain so
the wall of the reactor will have some
of the strongest magnets on the planet
suspending the particles in a perfect
donut ring that never touches the sides
the hydrogen atoms collide and fuse to
make another gas called helium releasing
vast amounts of energy in the process
that energy can be used to make
electricity but importantly the reactor
can be switched off in seconds so
there's no risk of a Fukushima style
meltdown this will be the heart of the
reactor and it will contain the most
mind-boggling extremes of temperature
over here will be the plasma an attempt
of 150 million degrees just 10 meters
this way will be the Magnus temperature
minus 269 almost absolute zero you'll
have the hottest and the coldest points
of the universe right here in the South
of France to prevent runaway climate
change the world needs to ditch fossil
fuels by 2050 nuclear fusion could be
the backup to renewable energy just a
pineapple sized amount of hydrogen has
the energy of 10,000 tons of coal you
need massive predictable continues okay
energy supply and it's why our ability
will not be enough so when there is no
Sun when there is no wind you could use
your fusion previous attempts at fusion
have been too small to extract usable
energy
this is scaled up a 15 billion pound
project with the European Union United
States Russia and China all involved the
energy that powers the Sun and stars is
being brought down to earth Thomas More
Sky News